hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña en la ley de na ella es
periodista argentina especializada en
deportes una de las primeras mujeres en
formar parte de este universo y la
protagonista de un hecho histórico ella
es la primer mujer en la historia de la
televisión nacional en comentar los
partidos de la selección masculina de
fútbol un rol en el que ya debutó con
dos encuentros de las eliminatorias
rumbo al mundial qatar 2022 en sus 25
años de carrera se desempeñó en las más
diversas tareas del periodismo deportivo
y ahora ocupa un lugar históricamente
reservado para los hombres ángela lerena
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24 que tal santiago muchas
gracias por la invitación angela bueno
uno de tus primeros comentarios por lo
menos público cuando se dio a conocer la
noticia fue voy a citar te escribiste en
tus redes sociales que la nena que se
enamoró del fútbol contra viento y marea
en la que dormía mirando a los pósters
de la selección va a comentar argentinas
angela cómo es ser digamos una fanática
del deporte desde chica y cuáles serían
esas dificultades no esos vientos y esas
mareas que tuviste que atravesar
abrirse camino en el mundo del
periodismo deportivo particularmente en
el fútbol no dominado por los hombres y
donde hay un machismo bastante arraigado
y bueno la dificultad empieza cuando sos
chiquita o sea cuando yo era niña hace
muchos años no era común por ejemplo que
a las mujeres nos regalaran una pelota o
nos regalaron una camiseta tampoco nadie
me llevaba al estadio a ver partido de
fútbol y por ahí era común y todavía a
veces lo es que cuando la mujer quería
opinar sobre fútbol hacer alguna
consideración bueno porque el lateral
derecho y güidi izquierdo le dijera no
vos no porque esas mujeres así fue mi
infancia no fue que me costará mucho que
ser incluida en cada uno de estos dos de
estos acontecimientos sociales que
vinculan al fútbol después ando empecé a
trabajar como periodista deportiva bueno
al decidir estudiar periodismo deportivo
también mi familia se preguntaba pero de
qué vas a vivir nunca vas a conseguir
trabajo
una vez que conseguí trabajo me costó
mucho crecer dentro de edad de la
estructura de la empresa periodística en
la que la que trabajaba los varones
crecían más rápido y bueno así fue estos
años por ahí a la mujer le cuesta un
poco más conseguir prestigio conseguir
credibilidad y también que se le asignen
lugares
relacionados con el conocimiento y no
solo con cuestiones estéticas o casi
decorativas bueno precisamente sobre
este punto que te quería preguntar
porque existía o existe todavía no un
rol bastante naturalizado para la mujer
en los programas de deporte no el de la
mujer sexy vestida sensualmente junto a
un hombre de traje no eso ha cambiado
cree esto y sucedió en alguna
oportunidad de estar en ese lugar tener
que enfrentarte a algún pedido de ese
tipo
si me sucedió que quisieran encasillarme
en ese lugar sobre todo cuando cuando
era joven cuando recién empezaba y bueno
me puse muchas veces tuve que decir no
yo así no me he visto está esta prenda
de vestir no es para mí y bueno había
resistencia del otro lado porque es
justamente lo que se buscaba cuando la
mujer empieza a entrar en el mundo del
periodismo deportivo se busca que entre
por el lado de la estética y yo me opuse
a hacer solamente algo algo físico o no
algo algo estético un adorno en los
programas en los que participaba y
siempre defendí mi derecho a tener un
rol profesional de opinión de análisis
de información que no tuviera que ver
con exhibir mi cuerpo de una forma sexy
y bueno eso lo sostengo de todas maneras
hay mujeres que que eligen mostrar ese
costado sexy y también está bien el tema
es que no nos dejen afuera del
conocimiento no de de poder ejercer como
profesionales independientemente de
nuestra estética absolutamente ahora era
cuando comenzaste en el periodismo
deportivo casi no había mujeres
realmente fuiste una de las pioneras
hace 25 años en argentina durante todo
este tiempo de carrera percibida
alguna evolución importante en términos
de género o no tanto
y muchísimo por empezar hay muchas más
mujeres periodistas deportivas
tenemos roles más prestigiosos y más
importantes y más vinculados como te
decía la cuestión profesional pero
además hay muchas más mujeres en los
estadios hay muchas más mujeres jugando
al fútbol a quien en argentina ahora por
el tema de la pandemia no pero en
general se solían ver mujeres jugando en
las canchas de fútbol 5 con las amigas
el torneo femenino de fútbol en
argentina es profesional desde hace un
año por primera vez en la historia
también así que es evidente el
crecimiento y también hay más mujeres
como telespectadoras y por eso las
empresas televisivas de deportes aquí en
argentina se están dando cuenta de que
para atraer ese público femenino
necesitan tener mujeres en pantalla
también es todo parte del mismo
crecimiento
angela esto es un hito por supuesto que
tiene que ver por supuesto muchísimo con
su empuje personal también profesional
pero crees que también es fruto digamos
en parte al menos de una conquista
colectiva me refiero al contexto no al
movimiento masivo el crecimiento de
mujeres que salieron a las calles de
argentina con reclamos históricos
desde el 2015 con el ni una menos la
marea verde de mujeres que se visibilizó
como nunca en la historia viendo la
despenalización del aborto crees que
este contexto colaboró en que hoy ocupa
este lugar
sí seguro santiago es indudable porque
este movimiento de mujeres en argentina
que tiene reclamos diversos que como vos
decías tiene en el reclamo por la
despenalización del aborto un espacio
donde nos encontramos pero además se
está transformando todos los espacios
profesionales educativos e incluso
familiares no muchas mujeres diciendo
bueno yo quiero que este espacio no
tenga más la perspectiva masculina que
tenga una perspectiva diversa y en el
mundo del deporte somos un montón de
mujeres y también muchos hombres y otras
diversidades que queremos tener un
espacio diverso tener un espacio que no
sea estrictamente masculino pero además
un espacio en el cual tampoco haya
xenofobia ni homofobia por supuesto
tampoco en misoginia ni violencia y
bueno con esto tiene que ver la
diversidad con aceptarnos todos como
somos y creo que el movimiento de las
mujeres nos está enseñando mucho sobre
esto y más allá de que yo hice los
méritos personales para ser la elegida
entre todo el universo de mujeres el
empuje no lo está dando realmente el
movimiento de mujeres que también empuja
el fútbol femenino por ejemplo en el
encuentro
entre el mundo del deporte y el
movimiento de mujeres está haciendo que
las mujeres ganemos espacio y
visibilidad algo que te caracteriza
además por supuesto de tu
profesionalismo de toda tu trayectoria
es que además manifestar abiertamente
tus posturas ideológicas políticas
incluso militares determinadas causas
pagadas ha tenido que pagar algún precio
por eso
bueno y empresas a las que no les gusta
me he tenido que ir me han despedido de
empresas periodísticas hay otras de las
que me he tenido que ir porque me
avisaron que en estas condiciones no iba
a poder subir no iba a poder ascender no
iba a poder crecer dentro de la empresa
justamente por expresar opiniones que no
tienen que ver con lo deportivo pero yo
tomé la decisión de usar el espacio de
visibilidad que tengo para difundir
causas en las que creo todos
reproducimos el mundo cuando cuando
hablábamos cuando emitimos su opinión
cuando emitimos ideas o incluso cuando
hacemos una crónica periodística
entonces yo elegir que esa imagen del
mundo que yo quiero reproducir sea una
imagen más sana inclusiva en la cual
todos y todas puedan encontrar su lugar
no me interesa reproducir los mismos
clichés que generan tanta exclusión
porque yo logré estar incluida a
reproducir ideas que excluyen a los
demás no es algo que me interesa me
interesa reproducir ideas que yo creo
que son positivas para la sociedad
porque tiene que ver con la inclusión de
todos y todas
para paralelamente no a tu profesión en
el periodismo deportivo desarrollar
actividades en defensa de la profesión
periodística participando activamente en
el sindicato de prensa argentina
hablamos de si prueba angela encontrar
más machismo en el periodismo digamos en
general en el mundo del fútbol del
deporte
el periodismo es más machista que el
mundo del deporte aunque parezca un
contrasentido porque siempre pensamos
que son los deportistas en especial los
deportistas varones los que más se
resisten el ingreso de la mujer pero no
los futbolistas en este caso que es con
quienes trabajo han sido mucho más
abiertos por hay que colegas que bueno
como estamos compitiendo de alguna
manera por los mismos puestos a veces se
esgrimen el género como un argumento en
contra mío o de otras mujeres y buenos
ojos creo que si lo único que tienen
para esgrimir en mi contra es mi género
es de alguna manera un elogio a mi labor
profesional porque si realmente hubiera
problemas con mi labor profesional
apuntarían ahí las críticas así que lo
tomo con tranquilidad hay gente que se
resiste a los cambios hay gente que cree
que pierde poder y pierde privilegios si
se le cede lugar o si no si se permite
que las mujeres ganen espacio pero bueno
las mujeres no vamos a retroceder el
espacio lo estamos ganando por nuestro
mérito por nuestro esfuerzo por nuestro
trabajo
los demás tendrán que adaptarse y
hablando de este no retroceder angela
que se viene de ahora en más no que
desafíos que dan es necesario que esto y
un proceso de cierta naturalización de
esta mayor presencia femenina en el
universo del fútbol
estoy seguro en algún momento dejará de
ser noticia que una mujer comenta la
selección y el camino para que eso se
naturalice es hacerlo es seguir
comentando yo comento también aquí en
argentina fútbol femenino hago campo de
juego que es la posición que está en el
césped en los partidos de fútbol
masculino de primera división aquí para
la señal tnt sports que es la que tiene
los derechos y bueno la presencia de
mujeres por supuesto no soy la única
somos muchas no las suficientes todavía
pero somos unas cuantas nuestra
presencia en nuestro trabajo profesional
nuestro esfuerzo ver que ocupamos esos
espacios con calidad es lo que hace que
se naturalice y hoy los los niños los
jóvenes ya están acostumbrados a ver
mujeres ya no tienen la misma postura de
los adultos aquí en argentina y todavía
colegas profesionales adultos hombres
que siguen diciendo las mujeres no
pueden hablar de fútbol y trabajan a
nuestro lado y nos ven como trabajamos y
siguen insistiendo con esas ideas los
jóvenes en su mayoría ya no son así ya
tienen naturalizado que una mujer buena
es buena independientemente de su género
esto te lo pregunto no por el hecho de
ser mujer no sino por un estilo propio
personal
qué diferencias en tu estilo con este
aspecto de muchísimos hombres en la
escena del periodismo deportivo por
ejemplo luego de tus comentarios son
muchísimas personas han destacado que tu
discurso es por decirlo de alguna manera
menos belicista menos de confrontación
al describir las jugadas etcétera
con eso tiene que ver con que dentro del
periodismo deportivo considero que estoy
en el grupo que por supuesto no es sólo
femenino de periodistas que quieren
destacar el juego y no hablar solamente
del resultado aquí hay también por el
impacto que genera y por el rating que
genera la cantidad de espectadores que
suman a una tendencia dentro del
periodismo deportivo a la pelea la
discusión por ahí a debatir durante una
hora entera de televisión por una falta
de un futbolista a otro si hubo mala
intención en ese futbolista o no por hay
quedarse en un penal durante todo un
programa gritando discutiendo bueno a mí
no me gusta ese tipo de periodismo desde
hace muchos años que decidí que lo mío
va a ser analizar el juego y bueno por
ese lado uso por ahí un vocabulario que
tiene que ver con color lúdico no más
allá de que hay mucho en juego estoy
comentando la selección argentina que se
juega nada más y nada menos que su
participación en la próxima copa del
mundo pero no deja de ser un juego y me
gusta usar un vocabulario que analice
los movimientos de los futbolistas no
que ponga todo en términos de ganar o
perder
eso le quita lo apasionante al deporte
el deporte no es sólo es acerca del
resultado sino que es acerca del juego y
eso es lo que trato de hacer en mi
comentario creo que sí que tengo un
estilo lo estoy formando recién empiezo
a comentar pero es un estilo que va por
ese lado ángela lerena muchísimas
gracias por habernos dado este tiempo
france24 ha sido realmente un placer
bueno muchísimas gracias para mí también
abrazo para todos desde buenos aires
muchísimas gracias angela nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com
[Música]
y